if I took my shirt off right now I look
like the melting candle from Beauty and
the Beast you know I go to the gap on my
38:32 they're like no we don't Diana
okay give it there so a guy he was like
legit 45 years old going to work on a
scooter suit helmet scooter grown man
like this smiling just gliding down the
street I was like do you think your
wife's not cheating on you I had a PhD
but I had a PhD in 1990 okay when nobody
had that alright there were no
support groups I was just the weird kid
that bit people beautiful my baby two
years old half Puerto Rican half Italian
I named her West Side Story she's a
toddler but she's a woman she's just a
miniature baby woman I'll come home
should be like look who decided to show
up my crayon so like do you have another
family or like I've been gone for ten
minutes